are you guys doing we're great how are
you I'm doing good so I might have
cheated and I know someone I'm not going
to reveal who we'll see if you can
figure it out who's involved in the
production and knows the three of you so
I got individual questions for the three
for each of you and let's see if you can
guess who it is who asked for Sammy who
is ketchup and who is mustard from Milly
season three yeah you'll probably like
once the show is released probably at
least like some behind-the-scenes
footage of and you guys will get to see
ketchup and mustard mash it okay Noah
how hard is it just like the face it's
nervous it's these are those questions
uh how hard is it to keep your voice
from sounding as deep as it really is
howdy how how hard is it to keep your
voice from sounding as deep as it really
is as deep as it really is what this is
what I was good this is what does that
mean like in a season 1 season no
changed a lot
oh so I did okay Oh Sean um so how hard
was it to keep your voice very hard oh
yeah okay I saw in the beginning of the
when we were doing the reading he was
like oh can you like talk like this when
you're doing the readings so like to
match it and I tried and it just sounded
it just sounded so weird so
exactly
Cal I was told to ask about your Georgia
allergies no totally
yeah it's all right so what's the what's
the deal with in Georgia at Georgia
Georgia you are like a mask and come
over to my house yeah medically the
beginning of spring I'm sure you're not
alone in that really no no seriously
because a lot of people have allergies
right so I have a thing called I'm sure
you've been asked a lot of stuff today
hopefully these are gonna be different
questions it's called get to know your
stranger things cast member I promise
these are harmless questions for each of
you a current favorite video game Red
Dead Redemption too you know but I mean
I've heard it's good okay
that counts we're gonna get to that okay
so like video games
I've always loved pac-man sure doesn't
that's totally legit though a current
favorite app on your phone oh I have
such a good app I have this app that
like you can type in any name and you
have them call you and so like if you
want to get out of the situation you
just like type their name and they'll
call you and you'll be like oh this
person's calling me I gotta go and it's
just so helpful amazing you should let
me know what this app is it's it's just
let me find it while Sadie gets her
answer
I think my phone all the time but I
guess when I am like I music
just like the Apple music or Spotify oh
yeah or my camera I use Spotify would
probably be my favorite music on there
oh look at that
Sadie's calling me that's so weird I
gotta go see it's amazing it's called a
call fake call okay I'm totally I'm
stealing that do you guys have a
favorite band
Calpurnia yeah I was like oh can it be a
group worse
oh so many a new addition
BBD did you just play someone a new
addition yeah Nirvana
and then Foo Fighters now just any David
girl I guess he's what we call talented
yes yes I'm not gonna say new addition
is enough I'm gonna say yes yeah I saw
that
right by the time I get there from
Boston leave me I am aware of Boston I
am now he likes me right
Oh what TV show would you love to guest
spot on oh oh I was gonna say I think
you could both use it Bob's Burgers
what's a would you play Bob's Burgers
one of like Linda all right okay
[Music]
[Music]
like never cut their kids I don't know
Oh like a cooking show would be fun you
know manza you know nails it on Netflix
I think we should do like a stranger
things nailed it in all of us oh that
would be so fun something like that
already know about all of us there's a
lot of brainstorming going on in this
area Hey
right exactly uh is there anything that
you guys have borrowed from set because
I know you went to legitimately stolen
yeah actually I took like something
weird set from season three I just I was
I can't say no sure I don't want you to
get in trouble yeah no I could say what
season three comes out I'll just post on
Instagram like I had to interview what's
your name again - Steve Steve with mr.
Steve so mr. Steve this is what I took
accidentally of course yeah I think I
accidentally like to comb your it was it
wasn't like the costume was just a good
warming jacket from wardrobe it's it's
just a jacket no no not like the nice
jacket like the hoodie I accidentally
took it home again accidently no but
like accidentally I mean I don't really
take any I try to be I don't want to
take any because like there's a lot of
expensive stuff if you gave me that look
like I shouldn't have said that
so basically you've borrowed something
but now you realize you shouldn't have
said it and it's now in the past we
never took it I have a bunch of other of
these quote-unquote questions but I
actually want to jump into some other
stuff before I run out of time which is
uh what was it like listen the show is
so popular and it's so well done there
has to be an element of when you're
coming back to film season 3 that like
do you feel any of that pressure because
of the fans and the popularity of the
show when you're first stepping back to
let read that script for the first time
or you sort of like the duffer's have
this it's going to be good
I had like complete faith in and
whatever season three is different but
it's I didn't I've never done it any of
the creators on the show it was just
about really you know what the fans
would like you know you never know if
anyone would like it or not you know so
it was always about the fans never
really about us I felt like we were very
close to me know what we can do the
chemistry is gonna be great so I feel
like we're all very like we were just
such a family and it's such a non it's
just not serious I mean of course it's
serious because there's a lot of
pressure but we all take it very like
light in a way and it's nice because
there's not it like relieves the
pressure and we kind of just all talk
and and and just let natural things
happen one of the things I really like
is when the duffer's are Sean or
whatever director is doing it come up
with these like cool camera shots and I
know it's more challenging to pull that
off because it requires more technical
stuff on set when you get told we're
gonna do this really cool shot are you
like bring it on you get more nervous
what is it like and what can you tease
about season 3 do you tell the crane
shots that they get they take forever
but you know we're all willing to do it
because obviously the result it's
incredible and matress and sean they're
all just so good at what they do
is there any really cool shot you're
looking forward to the oh yes there's
the last like episode remember on the
balcony thing and we were doing stuff
like
yep trying to holler is trouble I just
want oh it does the colors yeah colors
here I can't wait to yeah there's like
one like I said like the creams yeah
there's always I want to see how this
for sure what one of my last things uh
when you for season three how many of
the scripts do you guys have going in to
film and how much you sort of getting
like the first script and then it's well
usually it's the first four that we
start with like to do a table read and
from there they write the scripts as
we're going yeah so we got the first
four and then we had to wait like two
minutes basically until we were done
filming the first four episodes to get
five and six seven and eight and seven a
neighbor like we got like three months
later yeah
you